[Música]
el jefe de la misión de verificación de
naciones unidas en colombia caros ritmos
yo solicito al gobierno de colombiano
investigar el operativo militar en el
puerto de leguízamo en el departamento
de putumayo en el sur del país en el que
fallecieron al menos 11 personas
incluyendo cuatro civiles las
autoridades colombianas sostienen que
los fallecidos en este operativo del
pasado 28 de marzo en esta zona rural
eran miembros de un grupo disidente de
la ex guerrilla de las farc mientras que
organizaciones civiles aseguran que los
caídos eran líderes indígenas y
comunitarios la procuraduría de colombia
pidió a las fuerzas militares
información sobre la operación ya que
varias organizaciones sociales
denunciaron que se trata de los llamados
falsos positivos en colombia ante toda
esta lluvia de información y
contradicciones el medio colombiano
vorágine en alianza con cambio y el
espectador estuvieron en el lugar de los
hechos y para ello entonces quiero
saludar a jose guarnizo él es periodista
y director del portal vorágine uno
líderes de esta investigación jose
gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 la verdad
es un gusto poder saludarlo le pregunto
porque se forjó esta alianza entre
varios medios para tratar de llegar al
fondo de todo este asunto
muy buenos días gracias por esta
invitación pues básicamente
esta alianza surge en el lugar de los
hechos coincidimos periodistas de
vorágine el espectador y la revista
cambio y rápidamente nos dimos cuenta de
la complejidad del caso que no todo era
blanco y negro y que tenía una cantidad
de matices y una cantidad de información
que teníamos que recopilar en un tiempo
muy corto y decidimos básicamente
dividirnos el trabajo compartirnos toda
la información de poniendo cualquier
tipo de competencia que suele haber en
estos casos entre medios de comunicación
y entendiendo que el país necesitaba
saber de la manera más fidedigna posible
todo lo que había pasado y no solamente
a través de testimonios sino a través de
pruebas
y de indicios que fuimos encontrando en
el camino
hablando de las pruebas los indicios que
evidencias entonces ustedes encontraron
en su investigación que contradicen la
versión oficial de todos estos hechos
lo primero es que en el lugar donde el
28 de marzo el ejército llevó a cabo un
operativo y había personas civiles esto
porque se estaba dando en ese momento la
culminación casi de una de un bazar que
hizo la comunidad en el territorio había
niños y mujeres embarazadas de personas
de la tercera edad que estaban
concluyendo en ese lugar eso es lo
primero que contradice un poco la
versión oficial que indicaba que no
había civiles en el lugar y segundo que
no todas las personas que fueron dados
de baja utilizando un término militar es
decir personas muertas en ese operativo
eran combatientes qué quiere decir esto
que para el momento en el que se
desarrollaron los hechos no se
encontraban armadas
también las autoridades colombianas las
autoridades del ejército de colombia
aseguran que no era un bazar de una
comunidad sino que ahí se estaba
vendiendo pasta de coca y realizando
actividades ilícitas porque el ejército
colombiano tiene esta versión de los
hechos contrastante con ustedes que
dicen que era pues la comunidad civil
que estaba realizando este bazar
hay que decir que en el lugar si había
personas armadas de un grupo de las
disidencias de las farc al menos
nosotros pudimos conocer que habían al
menos cinco personas armadas mezcladas
con la comunidad en un territorio donde
alejado de digamos de las urbes de las
ciudades donde suele haber pues un
control territorial por parte de estas
organizaciones frente a que era un pasar
cocalero pues
llama la atención que dentro de las
incautaciones que hizo el ejército no
había coca no había pasta de coca no
hubo ninguna incautación de este tipo
entonces ahí digamos ahí hay un elemento
también a tener en cuenta frente a lo
que se estaba desarrollando los bloques
y ahí hay que decir y que pues hay
decenas de testimonios de fotografías y
demás es que en ese bazar se estaba
entiendo comida y licor fue un bazar que
reunió a veredas de muy cercanas incluso
no solamente de colombia sino de ecuador
y del perú porque este este territorio
que queda a orillas del río putumayo
pues ahí es una especie de vértice
en el que quedan muy cercanas
comunidades de ambos países jose también
hay denuncias de alteración de la escena
de donde ocurrieron todos los hechos de
manipulación del oscar a los cadáveres
los cuerpos de las víctimas es real esta
información de una manipulación por
parte de las autoridades digamos del
ejército colombiano de las víctimas que
allí estuvieron
si nosotros conocimos un informe de la
fiscalía que indica que los combates se
realizaron entre las 7 de la mañana y
las 9 de la mañana y solamente hasta las
2 y 30 de la tarde el personal de la
fiscalía del cpi encargados de hacer los
actos urgentes es decir los
levantamientos a los cadáveres y las
inspecciones técnicas a cadáveres fueron
enterados hasta esa hora hay un lapso de
unas cuatro horas y media en que el
ejército estuvo solo en el lugar de los
hechos y también conocimos unas
fotografías que no las publicamos por su
crudeza y porque van en contra de la
dignidad de las personas muertas pero si
conocemos unas fotografías en las que se
ve a un joven un menor de edad que murió
en esos enfrentamientos en un momento
sin fusil y luego en una lancha de la
fuerza armada con fusil nosotros pusimos
a un un experto forense que analizará
estas fotos y éstas y él y él el
dictamen que el que él da frente a este
material probatorio es que hubo arrastre
que hubo manipulación
movimientos de estos cuerpos y esto se
desarrolló antes de que llegara el cti
de la fiscalía dado que según lo que
aprecia el forense es que estas
fotografías fueron tomadas aun si me lo
permiten ese es un tema muy muy fuerte
pues es un cadáver que estaba que una
persona que había muerto en un lapso de
dos horas no más de dos horas claro
también esto concuerda con las denuncias
también que esta operación tendría
incluidos los llamados en colombia'
falsos o positivos pero también hablamos
del operativo como tal donde murió el
presidente de la junta de acción comunal
pero también una mujer en embarazo y una
menor de edad a estos últimos el general
del ejército colombiano zapatero se
refirió como combatientes realmente
estos eran combatientes
el presidente de la junta de acción
comunal debiera hernández y su esposa
anna maría arias no estaban armados en
el momento en que ocurrió el operativo
del ejército creo que el mismo ejército
ha reconocido que estas dos personas no
estaban armadas nosotros también
conocimos una fotografía que muestra los
dos cadáveres en el momento en que caen
y en ninguno de los dos casos hay armas
el digamos lo que sucedió con anamaría
también tiene tiene un ingrediente
adicional y es que ella murió desangrada
y estuvo durante una hora y media
esperando un auxilio y no hubo quien la
socorriera nosotros hablamos con la
persona que el auxilio que intentó
auxiliarla y lo que dice es que en ese
momento había una situación de combate
de disparos por todos lados y no hubo
quien le prestaran los primeros auxilios